realiza una tabla y resuelve y dice el
problema si tienes 50 onzas de una
solución salina al 25% es decir una
mezcla de agua con sal entonces cuántas
onzas de solución salina al 10% debes
agregar para terminar con una nueva
solución salina al 15% y bueno pues para
resolver este problema qué te parece si
hacemos en principio la tabla así que
aquí voy a poner la cantidad total que
tenemos de la solución la cantidad total
de solución que tenemos aquí voy a poner
el porcentaje que tenemos de salinidad
es decir el porcentaje de sal que
tenemos y aquí voy a poner la cantidad
total de sal que tenemos la cantidad
total de sal que tenemos recuerda que
estamos hablando de soluciones salinas
una parte es agua y la otra parte de sal
y vamos a ver nuestra cantidad inicial
nuestra cantidad inicial déjeme
escribirlo aquí nuestra cantidad
inicial fue de 50 onzas entonces aquí le
voy a poner que son 50 onzas y estas 50
onzas eran una mezcla salina
al 25% por lo tanto el porcentaje de sal
que tienen es un 25 por ciento y después
aquí voy a poner la cantidad total de
sal que tienen estas 50 onzas que
esencialmente es un 25 por ciento de
estas 50 onzas y un 25 por ciento lo
mismo que tomarme un cuarto entonces un
cuarto de 50 es 12.5 de estas 50 onzas
12.5 onzas son de sal si tenemos una
solución salina al 25% ahora bien todo
esto es lo que tiene que ver con la
solución inicial pero esta solución
inicial le vamos a agregar una cierta
solución salina al 10% la cual voy a
llamar solución agregada y si te das
cuenta en esta ocasión no nos dice
exactamente cuánto estamos agregando de
hecho estos justos la pregunta y bueno
como no sabemos cuánto vamos a agregar
vamos a decir que es x
pero lo que sí sé es que esta nueva
solución que vamos a agregar debe de
estar al 10% de salinidad es decir es
una solución salina al 10% y bueno
utilizando lo mismo que hicimos aquí
arriba si nosotros lo que queremos saber
es la cantidad total de sal que tiene
esta solución agregada habrá que
multiplicar el 10% por x es decir punto
1 por x porque por ejemplo si aquí fuera
50 entonces tendríamos que multiplicar
10% por 50 onzas y si fuera a 25 onzas
sería 10 por ciento por 25 onzas pero en
este caso como tenemos x onzas entonces
la cantidad de sal es 10 por ciento de
estas equis onzas y bueno si nosotros
combinamos estas dos soluciones tanto la
solución inicial como la solución
agregada vamos a obtener una solución
resultante le voy a poner así y bueno la
cantidad total de solución resultante
que va a haber pues es la cantidad total
de solución inicial más la cantidad
total de solución agregada es decir 50
más x porque no sabemos cuánto vamos a
agregar y lo que queremos
esta solución resultante esté a un 15%
de salinidad sea una solución salina al
15%
por lo tanto 15% aquí y aquí está lo más
importante de este problema yo lo que yo
sabe es pues la cantidad total de sal
que va a tener esta solución resultante
y si te das cuenta la podemos calcular
de dos maneras la primera manera es
decir bueno tenemos el 15 por ciento de
salinidad ya esto lo voy a multiplicar
por la cantidad total de solución que
hay es decir 50 más x esto si lo
queremos obtener de la misma manera que
lo obtuvimos en las dos filas anteriores
ahora también hay otra manera de hacerlo
podríamos sumar la cantidad de sal que
hay en las dos soluciones anteriores es
decir en la solución inicial y en la
solución agregada es decir que esto es
exactamente igual a sumar la cantidad de
sal que hay en la solución inicial más
la cantidad de sal que hay en la
solución agregada es decir 12.5 más 0.1
x más 0.1 x y bueno esto es porque es
justo lo que queremos que la cantidad de
sal que nosotros estamos agregando
la inicial nos den la cantidad de sal de
la solución resultante y adivina que
aquí ya obtuvimos una ecuación con una
incógnita por lo tanto de aquí ya
podemos despejar la x es una ecuación de
primer grado y recuerda que x es justo
atrás lo que vamos y bueno 0.15 por 50
es lo mismo que 7.5 y después 0.15 por x
me da 0.15 x 0.15 x 57.5 mientras que el
otro lado me queda 12.5 más 0.1 por
equis y ahora si lo que hago primero es
restar 7.5 de ambos lados de la ecuación
que voy a obtener déjame cambiar de
color y aquí voy a restar 7.5 y aquí
también voy a restar 7.5 de este lado
del lado izquierdo estos dos se van y me
queda que 0.15 x es igual a 12.5 menos
7.5 lo cual es 5
simple y sencillamente 5 más 0.1 x
y ahora lo que voy a hacer es restar 0.1
x de ambos lados de la ecuación y menos
0 punto lo voy a poner 0.10 x y del otro
lado menos 0 puntos 10 x recuerda que
estos dos números son exactamente lo
mismo de tal manera que del lado derecho
se van a cancelar y del lado izquierdo
me queda 0.05 x es igual a 5 y ahora si
divido todo entre 0.05 con esto voy a
obtener el valor de x todo entre 0.05
estos dos se cancelan y me queda que x
es igual a 5 entre 0.05 que es lo mismo
que 5 entre 120 avon que es lo mismo que
20 por 5 lo cual es 100 x es igual a 100
perfecto y realmente está perfecto
porque x era lo que queríamos es decir
vamos a tener que agregar 100 onzas de
solución salina al 10% para que
obtendremos una solución de 150 onzas
con una salinidad del 15 por ciento y
ahora si se multiplicó 100 onzas por 10%
me va a quedar 10
y 12.5 más 10 onzas esto me va a dar
22.5 y date cuenta qué 22.5 es el 15 por
ciento de 150 de 150 onzas y perfecto lo
hemos logrado